mk ultra
so not a myth not a myth so this is a
fascinating human experimentation
program
uh undertaken by the cia to develop
procedures for using drugs like lsd to
interrogate people
through
let's say psychological manipulation and
maybe even torture
the scale of the program is perhaps not
known
uh how do you make sense that this
program existed again you've got to look
through the lens of time you've got to
look at where we were historically at
that time there was the peak of the cold
war
our enemies were doing the same kind of
experimentation it was essentially a
another space race what if they
broke through a new
weapon technology faster than we did
what would that mean for the safety and
security of of the american people
so
right decision or wrong decision it was
guided by
and informed by national security
priorities
so from this program that was designed
to
use drugs to drive interrogation and
torture people was born something very
productive
operation stargate
which was a chance to use remote viewing
and metaphysics to try to collect
intelligence now even though in the end
the outcome of mkultra and the outcome
of stargate were mixed nobody really
knows if they did or didn't do what they
were supposed to do
we still know that to this day
there's still a demand
in the us government and ncia for people
who have sensitivities to
ethereal energies
uh by the way is there any proof that
that kind of stuff works or is
it just shows
it shows that there's interest it shows
that there's openness to consider those
kinds of things but is there any
evidence that that kind of stuff works
if there's evidence i haven't seen it
yeah
speaking
from a science-based point of view only
if energy and matter
can always be exchanged
then a person who can understand and
and
become sensitive to energy is a person
who could
become sensitive to what does become
matter
yeah i mean
the basics of the physics might be there
but a lot of people probably are
skeptical i'm skeptical too but i'm just
like you should be open-minded right i
mean that's that's that's actually you
know
that's what science is about is remain
open-minded even for the things that are
long shots because those are the things
that actually define scientific
revolutions
you